what is the best thing about Martin
O'Malley the best thing about Martin
O'Malley is that he is the perfect
understudy he's putting himself in a
position to be there in case Hillary
Clinton fails and he's doing it in a way
that is appropriate to the situation
he's not attacking her in a way that
would alienate any of her supporters
he's also able to create some contrast
with her and to energize the progressive
base a little bit to kind of to charge
up Clinton give her you know give her a
little bit of competition trade Wall
Street gay rights so and you know he's
an attractive young vibrant qualified
perfect understudy role quiet you know
he's not he's not gonna step on the toes
of the main diva but he's gonna make her
feel a little pressure which is kind of
that good what you gotta do yeah and he
seems like a cool dude I mean he's in a
band
he actually I get him on his email list
if he seems like he has an actual life
and he's a good person he has a
personality is not a wooden politician
you know again he just he plays the role
perfectly in a weird way by being
between Bernie Sanders who's to the left
of him but then obviously also being to
the left of Hillary he sort of
positioned himself like a few think
Bernie's too much and yours not into
Hillary's establishment stuff I'm the
guy again his you know his primary role
here is to be there in case Hillary
Clinton flames out giving the Democrats
a credible nominee yeah which Bernie
Sanders probably isn't all right what is
the worst thing about martin O'Malley
the worst thing about martin O'Malley
and I would not have said this a month
ago is Baltimore for for better or for
worse everyone in the country now
associates Baltimore with you know the
enormous civil rights struggle of our
time which is police reform mmm-hmm
with endemic poverty and everyone's
gonna ask the same questions of him over
and over and over again what did you do
as a mayor yeah I think his biggest
attack dog is gonna be David Simon
creator of The Wire and Baltimore Sun
crime reporter who hates Martin O'Malley
and is not going to shut up about it
so Martin O'Malley is going to be dogged
by his hometown
from the day he announced is that a
little crazy considering he's not mayor
right now I mean this current thing
obviously this is been going on for a
long time of course but that this
current situation isn't under his watch
it's crazy but frankly it's no crazier
than holding anyone else accountable for
what happened on their watch O'Malley is
going to be called to account for his
record in in Baltimore and it is a mixed
record and it's now a record that's
associated and in the minds of Americans
with something awful that's gonna be
really really really hard for him to
over write is that fair though because
he obviously wasn't mayor in this most
recent group of events in Baltimore I
gotta say I think it is fair I mean it's
not fair for people to blame him for
what happened in Baltimore it is fair
for people to ask all right
so crime went down but but why did it go
down did it go down everywhere how come
you didn't pay more attention to endemic
poverty what did you do at the time to
crack down on police brutality did your
fascination and and the buy-in that you
had this technocratic idea of crime
stats and precinct by precinct numbers
did that increase the tension between
poor african-americans and the police
those are real questions that he's going
to be asked over and over and over again
yeah all right well there you go Martin
O'Malley is he positioned perfectly by
being between Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton or is this situation in
Baltimore gonna haunt his campaign let
us know your thoughts in the comments
right down below